in höhe kummer mein schiff
gebt euch das mal eine riesige
unterirdische schlucht dings mit mein
schiff drin
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen ich bin heute ganz alleine
und ich habe auch gar keine themen am
start weil ich auch gar nicht weiß was
ich in dieser folge eigentlich machen
kann und wollte aber einfach nur eine
folge auf dem weg über eine sache reden
wollte und zwar den dran jeden tag mein
fries zu bringen den ich zurzeit ein
wenig verspüren wenn ich so rumlaufen
es ist halt schon recht cool geworden
muss ich sagen ich ernte erst mal hier
so ein bisschen weizen ab damit ich mir
daraus etwas zu essen machen kann ihr
wisst es freuen ich hab immer diesen
gewissen nahrungsmangel vorhanden
übrigens falls ihr euch fragten wieso
sieht das anders aus wann hast du das
gebaut
ich habe die fries folge gar nicht
gesehen wo du da oben das alles gebaut
hast das hab ich sogar nicht mal aufs
spiel gemacht weil es ist uns ja erlaubt
hier auch spielen dass man am ende
einfach eine schöne stadt hat wir
vertrauen einander dass man nicht weiß
macht und alles mögliche ist auch bisher
nicht passiert aber ich habe einen
livestream gemacht und zwar
wenn ihr die folge seht vorgestern und
der live-stream fand ich richtig gut ich
möchte im revier revue passieren lassen
zudem live stream und zwar habe ich den
halt nur einen eigenen stunde vorher
angekündigt und dafür waren einfach ist
jetzt etwas kaputt oder nicht dafür
waren halt einfach irgendwie höchstzahl
5000 leute da oder so was ich schon mal
recht stark finde dafür das ist einfach
mitten in der woche war es nur eine
stunde vorher angekündigt habe da bin
ich auf jeden fall stolz auf euch ich
weiß andere streamer haben vielleicht
mehr oder weniger ich weiß nicht ich
gucke selber recht wenig streams aber
ich muss echt sagen ich bin stolz auf
euch und deswegen einfach mal ein
standing ovations meine lieben freunde
nur an
da muss ich echt sagen weil ich positiv
von überrascht fand ich richtig gut und
kann mich da halt einfach nur für
bedanken
und ich denke ich werde jetzt mal die
höhen zu machen die ich im livestream
angekündigt hatte aber da nicht gemacht
haben und ich mache die hedge und zwar
eigentlich brauche ich dafür gar nicht
mehr so viele sachen ich würde sagen wir
jetzt einfach mal los und ziehen in der
richtung in die wir bisher noch nicht so
wirklich gezogen sind und zwar leicht
von mir nicht ganz vielen dass da hinten
gegangen und da war auch schon egal
höhle aber ich weiß nicht ich da war ich
halt schon so drin und hab da schon
mittel in gekürzter wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal diese richtung und zwar
ruhig darüber reden dass ich immer
diesen drang verspüre jeden tag
minecraft fries zu bringen weiß am
anfang gesagt habe und zwar habe ich
halt diesmal keine thema am start
aber ich würde mich trotzdem freuen wenn
ihr halbwissen werden dabei zum thema
ist was mir ein bisschen auf dem herzen
liegt bezogen auf michael so viele haben
mich am anfang november oder mitte
november oder endet nur weil man immer
im november habe ich gefragt hey luca
machst du wieder deine minecraft
christmas kraft projekt also dieses
projekt was jetzt gerade läuft wobei
einfach in der winterwelt bisschen
spielt bei winterlicher musik und
atmosphäre ganz friedlich baut dann habe
ich halt einfach fries angefangen hab
mir gedacht okay jeden tag um minecraft
fries und ist doch ganz billig und somit
bearbeiten und so war ich hier halt
nicht soviel gearbeitet wie
beispielsweise bei micro facts wer in
welchen app sachen oder irgendwie sowas
das mach ich halt hier noch ganz locker
und mache hier nicht so viel mit
bearbeiten weil ihr das gewünscht wurde
und dann habe ich mir gedacht okay ich
eigentlich ganz frisch kann ich einfach
wieder so ein projekt klingen so ein
bisschen old school jeden tag aber was
mir auffällt dieses projekt er setzt er
nicht die anderen sachen die ich immer
noch nebenbei mache sowas wie fix oder
mops oder minecraft top 5 oder so ein
paar sachen kam mir schon schlug direkt
gefunden okay es ist keine flucht aber
es ist eine sehr geile höhle da gehen
jetzt einfach mal runter also was mir
also ein bisschen missverstanden den ich
missverstanden was ich so ein bisschen
vergessen habe mit zu bedenken ist dass
dieses projekt ja nicht die anderen
projekte von mir ersetzt sondern einfach
nur noch mit dazu kommt und deswegen
habe ich derzeit quad diese
doppelbelastung dass sich einerseits
oder was es dabei belassen haben
teilweise eine vierfach belastung dass
ich irgendwie studium die kreativen
videos lief ex oder top 5 oder sowas
dann dieses mike fries projekt und noch
freizeit und alles mögliche familie
unter einen hut zu zeit kriegen muss und
es ist schon anstrengend jeden tag
nachfolge zu bringen es ist natürlich
eigentlich wenn man zunimmt eine
viertelstunde ebene folge aufnehmen
bearbeiten und hochladen
aber da wird schon noch ein bisschen
mehr dazu und deswegen möchte ich euch
etwas kleines mitteile leiter also seid
jetzt nicht so traurig ich verkünde
jetzt nicht mein ausstieg aus diesem
projekt vor allem das geht halt nur noch
13 tage oder so aber ich werde auf jeden
fall die nächsten tage nicht jeden tag
was hochladen zum beispiel ihr seht die
folge gerade am donnerstag
und ich bin zum beispiel heute am
donnerstag auch in den ganzen tag weg
und kann nicht noch eine folge für
morgen aufnehmen ich nehme es übrigens
erst mal die ganzen kiez mit für den weg
weil ich den weg da so ein bisschen
schöner machen wollte und so dafür
brauchen wir auf jeden fall eine menge
kies und zwar kommt morgen schon mal
keine folgen fries der präfekt samstags
kommt dann wieder fries und ich denke
wir können eine ganz gute mischung
finden also es kommt was ich halt
einfach sagen möchte es kommt nicht
jeden tag jetzt bis weihnachten eine
folge fries das projekt bis weihnachten
das wissen die leute die aufmerksamen
aufmerksamen zuschauer von fries also an
weihnachten kommt dann vielleicht so
eine gemeinsame volk oder irgendwie
sowas obwohl ich an weihnachten halte
ich da bin
also ich fahre ab dem 21 den urlaub habe
ich ja gesagt aber ja also es wird nicht
jeden tag was jetzt kommen
von meike fries weil ich einfach ich
weiß nicht diese ersten zehn folgen ging
jetzt ganz gut klar ich möchte mich
wieder so ein bisschen auf die anderen
projekte konzentrieren so was wie top
fünf kräftigen ideen oder minecraft
fries oder eines macs oder
sachen oder weil sie nicht wie ich hätte
auch mal wieder lust auf irgendwelche
bett auf irgendwelche heimsieg runden wo
ich einfach wieder über thema rede
ich habe das damals schon wieder damals
mal gemacht wo ich über horror story
geredet habe die halt in echt so
passiert ist aber trotzdem extrem krank
ist einfach okay die höhle es irgendwie
doch nicht so geil ich komme hier schon
wieder raus
naja gut stand gehe ich hier halt wieder
hoch ist ihr was ich bin übrigens auch
ein richtiger kind schon wieder dunkel
draußen nicht ob ich jetzt schon wieder
verlaufen wie war doch da dahin ist zu
hause
ich sollte mir eventuell ein kompass
mitnehmen dann wenn ich doch so ein
bisschen gewappnet
hier ist aber genau auch keine höhle
spitze habe ich ihnen mal wassereimer
mit lässt sich ebenfalls oder so also
ich kriege es halt zeitlich nicht hin
jeden tag jetzt auch bis weihnachten der
folge zu machen ich hoffe mal das heißt
für euch irgendwie okay ist sauer aber
ich finde dann bevor ich mich hinsetze
und total stressig um 2 und nachts auch
eine folge aufnehmen erfolge kommen muss
finde ich dann halt nicht so cool und
die folgen werden noch dementsprechend
nicht so toll kann ich mir vorstellen
deswegen ich las dass die ganze kohle
übrigens hier liegen weil ich nur
diamanten möchte weil ich mir so ein
bisschen was leisten möchte jetzt in
minecraft ich werde den weg
wahrscheinlich später ähnlich
herausfinden so wie ich jetzt schon
wieder runter laufen bin ich glaube ich
immer hier in einen wassereimer mit dann
fließt das wasser an den schlecht weg
runter chef peter ich denke aber ihr
versteht was ich meine und ihr seid ja
auch eigentlich immer so auf meiner
seite wenn ich lache ich habe keine
änderung am start oder oma so geht's
schon wieder hoch und wieder runter die
spitze mitzuspielen cc spießten kreusch
das wasser als rutsche rutsche runter
runter irgendwie gar keine mops derzeit
am start war okay es gar nicht so tief
lag ich höre aber ich höre böse leutchen
bilde leute auch einen trieb an oder
creeper so schau mal hier noch ein
bisschen rum irgendwie das hier sind
diese räume die man richtig oft in höhe
kummer mein chef vor
gebt euch das mal eine riesige
unterirdische schlug dings mit mein chef
drin cool machen wir auch mal was
erreicht im projekt haben war mein chef
gefunden
ihr müsst jetzt irgendwo ein bisschen
was die ammann ähnliche seien auf jeden
fall schonmal emmelsum spitze das gold
also was ich sagen wollte ihr seid ja
meistens immer so auf meiner seite wenn
ich irgendwas bezüglich änderungen also
selbst keine richtige änderungen aber
auf jeden fall etwas das ein projekt
hier ein bisschen vernachlässigt wird
möchte ich nicht dass ihr sowas denkt es
ist halt einfach nur weil ich zur zeit
echt mega viel stress habe auch weil ich
halt einfach im urlaub bin was sie auch
auf tage da muss ich halt auch daneben
die acht neuen videos vorproduzieren das
jeden tag dazu ein video kommt bei das
muss schaltet erst mal hinkriegen alles
zu managen und der sagt nicht da ist
schon wieder eine schlucht ihrem start
lasst es die gleiche du kriegst du
hältst mich fast da reingeschossen du
kleine skelette du bist spitze vor war
das wieder knapp vom herzen vor kurzem
müssen jedoch jetzt irgendwo man
diamanten seien
ich klettere hier mal jetzt einfach
unterricht ob das ist obsidian was hier
so grün ist das habe ich mich letztes
auch schon mal gefragt was das für grüne
blöcke sind als ich mit max aufgenommen
hatte ich verletze folge war dass sogar
aber okay ich glaube das sind dann
wirklich obsidian blöcke fwg wie krass
das einfach ist das hier einfach noch so
eine schlucht ist oder das ist halt die
gleiche ich weiß gar nicht wo ich habe
richtig angst vor dem café chancen aber
ja das ist wirklich oxidieren das sieht
man schon viele andere themen habe ich
eigentlich gar nicht vorbereitet die
wollen eigentlich nur sagen dass ich
derzeit total den zeitdruck immer ab und
auf youtube immer noch so ein bisschen
zu kurz kommt was mir auch leid tut aber
das wird besser wenn ich aus dem urlaub
wieder zurück bin und dann wird sich
wieder um youtube gekümmert
und dann kommen ja mal schauen wie sich
das ganze noch entwickelt und ich werde
halt ja ich weiß nicht ich wiederhole
mich gar die ganze das tut mir leid aber
ich habe einfach keine themen
vorbereitet weil ich gleich auch schon
wieder schnell weg muss weil wir von der
uni sondern event planen müssen und das
ist halt das blöde ich meine
total viele leute machen mittlerweile
einfach youtube hauptberuflich ich mache
das hat noch nicht weil ich nebenbei
studieren und deswegen habe ich halte
diese doppelbelastung aber ich möchte
auch eigentlich gar nicht jetzt im
mitleid jedenfalls dass jetzt eine eine
ein oder andere so interpretiert und
jetzt in die kommentare schreibt ja du
musst ja nicht jeden tag ein video
machen
ich möchte aber ganz gerne das macht mir
auch spaß aber das blöde ist halt dass
ich halt dann immer so ein bisschen die
anderen sachen kommt man halt so
kurzweilig ein video machen dann kann
ich halt nicht wie die uni lernen das
sind diese ich glaub opportunitätskosten
heißt das einfach dass das ein
unternehmer anderen leidet also als
wirtschaftlicher begriff
opportunitätskosten das heißt wenn ich
das eine mache muss etwas anders darauf
verzichten das ist bei jeder tätigkeit
so das heißt wenn ich sogar
für die schule schwänzen und schlafe
dann ist sind die opportunitätskosten
dass das schlafen
wichtiger ist als juni für mich das sind
natürlich ganz individuelle sachen das
kann natürlich auch sein dass jemand von
euch jetzt sagt ich an seiner stelle
wird weniger für die uni machen aber
dafür mehr für youtube damit verdiente
geld habe mir ist das irgendwie also das
sind halt individuelle sachen und für
mich ist ich habe zeit beschlossen okay
minecraft ist ein projekt was nicht
ersetzend kommt für die anderen projekte
wie feld oder so sondern was nebenbei
kommt und das habe ich unterschätzt dass
es doch so viel arbeit ist obwohl ich
nicht so viel daran bearbeiter an den
folgen
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ich lade
davon jetzt nicht jeden tag noch was
hoch bis bissig die zeit vorbei
ich war davon nicht mehr jeden tag was
hoch bis das ganze
ich hab kein holz mitgenommen ich vogel
jetzt kann ich keine der putsch
erschießt mich abwählen sprach also noch
mal ich hab mir gedacht dass ich nicht
jeden tag also lade weil ich
unterschätzt habe
die was was fries trotzdem für ein
aufwand ist mit diesem letzten fragen
aussuchen und so ich meine fahren
aussuchen denkt man jetzt ok einmaliger
posten aber bei mir ist es halt nicht so
dass ich nebenbei wie andere youtuber
das einfach offen habe twitter
unternehmen bei auf pause clique und
dann auf ein paar dann auf eine frage
den raussuchen sondern vor dem video
schon recherchiere und schaue welche
fragen hatte ich noch nicht ich habe zum
beispiel eine riesige word-datei wo alle
fragen reingeschrieben sind die schon
mal hatte unterschreibt ja noch immer
die neuen fragen rein einfach das sicher
nichts wiederholt fragen werden sich nur
wiederholen wenn ich mit anderen leuten
aufnehmen und diese frage raussuchen
berliner nicht wissen hast du schon mal
beantwortet habe also dass wie ich das
mache jetzt halt noch mal so ein
stückchen nicht professionelle aber ich
möchte da halt einfach ein bisschen mehr
arbeit reinstecken
professionalität ist auch eine
individuelle sache auch man ich glaube
jetzt wieder viel zu vielen heißen brei
herum
ich sollte am besten einfach mal jetzt
diamanten finden
das wäre vielleicht eine ganz gute sache
wenn ich einfach mal diamanten finden
würde kann das vielleicht auch mal jetzt
hier irgendwie dilaver komplett kaputt
machen oder so bitte danke machen es
hilft ja es ist ruckelte bistum ich habe
echt ein problem
ich hab keine fackeln am start und ich
bin ja so behindert sagt die ganze zeit
ich habe kein holz am start
also habe ich denn die guten humor
sollten mein schiff dort holz luca ja da
suche ich mir hier raus jetzt noch ein
wenig die sticks natürlich zusammen das
dann einfach und dass du das letzte sein
was ich für diese folge mache deshalb
will das wird das letzte sein was ich im
dienst das netz ist er sich im leben tun
werde ich werde diese person umbringen
ich schaue auf jeden fall noch mal
hierhin ob ihr nicht doch irgendwie
diamanten am start sind weil lava nähe
ist denke ich mir mal so ok lava ich
bisschen affin mit diamanten
wenn das hier schon ein bisschen
gefährlich ist muss ja eigentlich was
sein was mir gefällt das heißt wir
schauen jetzt mal und natürlich freunde
als ob ihr auch diamanten am start sein
quatsch wir sind natürlich keine das ist
mal wieder mein glück meine lieben
freunde
ich finde gar keine diamanten max geht
eine höhle oder direkt die diamanten am
start und ich würde sagen damit okay ich
habe jetzt nicht so viel über fries und
weihnachtliche sachen geredet aber es
war ein thema was ich auf jeden fall
auch mal ansprechen wollte wie viel
arbeit fries für mich eigentlich ist und
dass das ganze jetzt ein bisschen
gedrosselt wird jetzt kommt ja auch noch
gerade so einen scheiß [ __ ] wille
jockey werde ich doch jetzt hier
untergeht
hier müssen doch diese erst mal richtig
viele mops am start
ich hatte mich diese barcelona ist für
mich echt kein
keinen keinen bock zu stark da kommt
jetzt auch noch ein kripperl denke ich
auch erst mal ich explodiere juckt mich
doch nicht
ich möchte nur diamanten meine lieben
freunde und hier sind wir bald keine das
kann halt nicht sein
jetzt ist hier lapislazuli das wieder
emeryville wollen ihr denn nicht nur
einfach diamanten sein oder so können
die hier nicht nur einfach irgendwo rum
schlummern
ich bin doch nur schon auf der richtigen
höhe oder ich bin auf höhe 13
wir müssen irgendwo diamanten seien
es ist unmöglich dass die kleinen sind
schon wieder anderen ohne diamanten
dies kann kann es denn wahr sein dass
hier in die acht mann egal ich möchte
nicht aufbringen ich würde sagen meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
würde ich mir eine bewertung freuen
oder würde ich sagen sehen uns in der
nächsten folge wieder wenn ihr dann
wieder bock auf fries habt oder irgend
einem anderen video und ich laufe
nebenbei ja noch ein bisschen rum aber
ich sehe hier immer noch keine diamanten
und es ist auch ehrlich als habe ich
schon wieder ausgeleuchtet der komplett
ohne die runde es ist egal ich würde
sagen ich verabschiede mich für diese
folge